gabriel boric y josé antonio kast van a
segunda vuelta en chile los dos
candidatos que lideran las encuestas
competirán por llegar al palacio de la
moneda boric un ex líder estudiantil
representa a la izquierda y es el más
joven de los siete candidatos que se
presentaron las elecciones el mismo
tiene 35 años la edad mínima para
postularse a la presidencia propone dar
un giro hacia un modelo de bienestar y
asegurar derechos sociales se trata de
que la esperanza legal el miedo en el
estallido social de 2019 jugó un papel
protagónico en apoyar el cambio de la
constitución representa a la coalición
apruebo dignidad que reúne al frente
amplio y al partido comunista
alianza que aprovechan sus detractores
para criticarlo lo atacan por su
inexperiencia y su falta de título
universitario también por su cambio de
postura en su respaldo al gobierno
venezolano que ahora rechaza el otro
extremo está el ultraderechista cast que
propone mantener el modelo neoliberal
promete imponer orden seguridad y
libertad tras dos años de protesta
social
guardar
esperar que la gente en mi caso botox
cast representa el partido republicano
está casado y tiene nueve hijos es un
activo miembro del movimiento católico
conservador angstadt es hijo de
inmigrantes alemanes su padre se alistó
en el ejército durante el régimen nazi
alemán sus detractores lo acusan por su
admiración a la dictadura de augusto
pinochet y de líderes controvertidos
como yahir bolsonaro o donald trump los
dos candidatos opuestos en sumisión a
tiza en la polarización chile celebrarán
la segunda vuelta el próximo 19 de
diciembre